on this episode we go into my office
we'd finally put Stefan to work halfway
through and I end it on probably the
most important thing I've ever said on
this show
[Music]
this is
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 1 64 of the ask gary me
show in my office i'm nice and cozy well
today's Friday I have to make it whoa
I literally just ii realize i have to
make an official prediction i am going
to houston if you haven't been following
along actually gonna send you guys this
this is a picture of me and AJ at every
game so that's fun
d-roc is back from Australia good to
have you back the rock you timed it well
I was away you were away but you missed
a couple episodes including the classic
in the gym episode if you're just
catching this this is 164 163 if you
haven't seen it yet because we put up
late last night good hustle there Stefan
on that if you have if you're just
seeing this now in your Facebook for
your YouTube make sure you watch 163
that was a classic askgaryvee history
thank you yes that definitely has trivia
all over it I will give my official Jets
prediction at the end of the show and
and speaking of the show India let's get
into the show
love it let's do it Roy asked apart from
consistency what's the smallest routine
that's made the biggest difference to
the askgaryvee show since starting uh
the friction between consistency and
constantly trying to evolve now you know
obviously like the show yesterday
outside not asking a question today now
bringing back the question of the day
India coming in somewhere along the line
instead of stunwin and and probably more
things that will continue if we're lucky
enough to have a run here it there's the
consistency of doing it and really
letting the essence of the show happen
you know what's really interesting is if
you look at the for all of you that have
watching by the way leave a comment if
you've watched every episode actually
what might do a pic where's the pumpkin
and we're left ready we'll tell you
about it later
the there's obviously a lot of themes
I'm not gonna change my mic pillars or
religious points of view on things but
the reinforcement it's been
I've been getting emails lately that's a
you know Gary it's funny I've watched
all 160 episodes and this theme has
really caught my attention but it took
me hearing you answer a question maybe
15 different questions with the same
theme different answers the same theme
to it really now just hit me like wow I
really now understand what you mean of
executions the game ideas should of
course ideas aren't [ __ ] but boy
everybody's got everybody's got an idea
things like that and so I think the
consistency of doing it the consistency
of there being four to 15 things I
believe in hard work you know not being
romantic about the current state of the
marketplace and always putting yourself
out of business being 5149 to the other
person so be like just actually being
authentic enough that you know yourself
that your answers aligned in that way
and then just making it interesting and
fun and and different settings the
outside energy mixed up with being in my
office the predictions at the end the
show those will go away after the
football season so you know just mixing
it up so putting pressure on the format
while letting the essence always be the
same being the same person even though
you grow up and mature and maybe change
your outfits grow facial hair get older
start losing hair but still always being
that same person but evolving with the
times thank you thank you know if you
picked up on that clap sky sky is magic
our sky is magic year sky ask Adele's
new album isn't streaming anywhere is
she romantic about selling albums or
leveraging people to buy music oh wait a
minute Stefan's just standing here and
if you're just I mean show that die rock
he's really truly just standing here one
of the things that makes me yawn I mean
really I know you've got to watch it for
editing purposes but you should be you
should be doing something stuff so let's
do a little Paris copy all right Adele's
new album is not streaming anywhere
right
music it's a really good question and
the truth is there's a time and a place
for you to do everything so we talked
about speck work here right do you rock
on his job on it right like like you do
something for free and it leads to what
you want to happen but look when you're
jay-z in the early days and nobody knows
who the hell you are it makes sense to
go to a club not get paid and spit your
fire because you're building leverage I
used to go and speak for free
often I don't do that anymore
because I have an alternative I am
demanded now Adele if her name was Sh'ma
Dell if SHM Adele came out with a new
album and nobody knows who she model is
hope
I don't follow music enough so if
there's a shame Adele I apologize but if
you're coming down and nobody knows who
you are you not only want to be on
streaming services you want to like show
up on Instagram people's accounts and
like sing you want to like go outside
and give people your free album like you
want exposure because that creates
leverage that you then can charge for
Adele doesn't have that problem and so
she's trying to maximize profits through
that channel versus the pennies that
screaming does it does two things it
makes for more money it gives her less
exposure by accident for people that
could find her through Spotify or other
places that have never discovered her
before from my point of view it's a fine
balancing act right I think if you look
at the people that pushed against
Napster or pushed against technology the
bands that pushed against MTV
historically that didn't make music
videos if you're too romantic for too
long you can get caught unless you're in
the top 1% I believe that there's an
absolute way to not conform to modern
marketing Allah Apple if your product is
disproportionately the best consistently
you can get away with acting differently
but if you look even at like actors at
the top of their game like a Will Smith
who made the same kind of movie for a
while
everybody has their day in time and so
my answer is if Adele has this read
properly that she doesn't need more
exposure she has a huge fan base she
just put out fire and it killed
look at Justin Bieber in parallel did a
lot of marketing a lot of Instagram a
lot of releasing a lot of stuff out
there and it really worked now the
question becomes he needed that because
he was in this funny spot does he do the
same thing next time or does he go a
little bit closer to where adele is if
Adele's over here the answer to the
question my friends is there's no
absolutes there is no right answer
there's moments in time like the first
question
there's knowing what to do at this
moment the things I knew running this
business at 600 people is very different
than what I did at four I don't say yes
I said no to 19 deals today I said yes
to every deal when we first started
right and so we just talked about we
just all got together on my team to talk
about how much book buying you have to
do for all my packages for the next book
I think we can all agree there's a lot
more books that you need to do to do the
things that I did through two years ago
for Jab Jab Jab right hook
cuz I'm busier I have more opportunities
I have more leverage this is where the
askgaryvee shows brand right has helped
me why don't you single I mean you're
just saying this is amazing why'd you
say hello
tell tell the vaynernation who you are
[Music]
yeah so we'd just was working on
something else I just said he's just
hanging out he said before we weird hey
my brother turned me on to the show his
brother and him now Know Who I am more
than they did before because this shows
working for me which then gave me
leverage to ask for 3,500 bucks to give
a keynote versus 2,000 bucks so this is
how it works guys you put in the work
for a year and a half you build up
leverage which then allows you to get
more stuff so Adele's move where a lot
of people might say oh Gary's gonna say
because I know a lot of you thought
there's all that's bad you're killing
exposure no it's it's balancing that
what's important is not reading your
Odin headlines and doing the thing that
Adele's doing too long too many times in
a row that now no 17-year old in America
or 15 year old even knows who you are
because they only live in those
platforms right all the bands that said
no to being the music on John Madden
football in 1999 2001 2004 2006 they
missed out on being good Charlotte good
Charlotte said yes they were willing to
give away the music or go find out how
the Black Eyed Peas worked will.i.am was
smart he's like Oh for TV commercial
for this Apple iPod thing okay we won't
be too fancy and the three big bands
that you've heard of that said no miss
the chance of being huge so yeah I even
say yes to things for free if the
exposure is disproportionately
unbelievable Saturday Night Live does
not need to pay me to show up and be in
an SNL because they're bringing me
something you with your local TEDx thing
in smugger mugga mugga iowa sorry to
pick on Iowa I love you Iowa like yeah
you got a problem because like I don't
want to come for those 40 people it's
just checks and balances and I love you
40 people but watch your show for free
it's I can't make it it's just an
equation
Adele's at that place where she can do
this right now but Adele needs to do
what I think I try to be really good at
which is don't read your headlines don't
get too fancy to not take a selfie if
you get too separated from that for too
long and you can do it
but if you do it for too long somebody
else is gonna come along and SHM Adele's
gonna be number one Modell's [ __ ]
pissed and hungrier it's [ __ ] the
Rocky movie right Rocky was hungrier but
then he got fancy in LA mr. t whip that
ass we can be the new Siskel and Ebert
this movie sucks [ __ ] I don't know it's
interesting huh
alright let's go Adam asked do you think
it's important for agency leaders to be
active on social do you weigh that when
hiring a leader at Vayner um look I do
think that somebody has to be a
practitioner or skilled in your craft so
yes I do weigh that but I do think we
have a machine here that if somebody's a
great executive and good at building up
people's talent knows how to do client
services understands the theory of of
marketing but hasn't used snapchat
Instagram Facebook enough to be a great
practitioner that we know that's
commoditized and that after 100 days at
Vayner we can get them to that place so
if they have enough of the other things
you don't be crushing it on Instagram to
be a leader at Vayner you have to
understand why Instagram is crushing it
and then put in the work once you start
here if you're good at leading the team
great with client services great
strategies created understanding how
things we have a lot of people that are
great at Facebook snapchat Instagram but
don't understand how beer is sold or how
soap is sold and we have to teach them
that if you're coming as a 42 year old
executive and done it your whole career
and you know that
so just teaching the white space so
that's the real answer you have to have
the attitude the the appetite and the
theoretical rationale to why these
things are working to get in the door
that was a nice tight answer oh yeah we
need to do more videos hey Gary
hey Todd you say ideas are crap you've
had six or seven and you big career tell
me last time you were pumped about your
biggest idea thanks man that was well
done that is the way to get on the show
get India's creative juices going we
need a little bit more creative video
questions this is a good string point
this we need that let's let's let's go
call to arms to the vaynernation to
better video question let's step it up
Jesus what's his name Adam todd todd
great job first of all the last idea
I've been really excited that's a really
good question I'm really excited about
my current ideas of big opportunities in
the business world so they're not very
specific but I'm in love with my thesis
of eSports and virtual reality in a
10-year window and so I just have to
make sure I don't get too far ahead of
it
but I'm very very very excited about
that I think I was very right about how
much brands and businesses were gonna
spend on social networks I don't think
people saw four or five years ago the
money allocation that's getting poured
into making videos and pictures for
these platforms that was exciting to me
it's been the backbone of that was the
strategy and then the execution was
vaynermedia that's when it works when
you have both right like you can work
your ass off if you're wrong if you're
like okay if I'm like okay guys VHS
tapes are coming back and if I start
building a company and hiring people
that are 58 years old that know how to
make like VHS tape like if I'm wrong all
our hustles for naught so you have to
have both I
I would say that um I would say the the
the the other thing that I can point to
is the askgaryvee show I don't know if
you heard about it but we're doing it
right now it's very meta I knew that I
was good at answering questions I could
feel at conferences that people would be
like holy crap that last 15 minutes that
was the bomb they were impressed by my
quickness in my craft it was a way to
show everybody that I know what I'm
talking about I mean people are stunned
I was with somebody yesterday people
don't realize that I don't know the
questions like you pick them yes I will
send you like the first one we did today
like I sent you like I'm looking I'm
watching you guys because I care about
you guys and I'm sending stuff but I
would say out of a week 25 questions I'm
sending you two so when people find that
out they're fascinated by it so I
thought this format would work for me I
thought it would elevate my leadership
around marketing and Technology thought
leadership and it has him and his brow
and many and many and many many many
many more of you and so that that idea
was percolating we did it at Hawk one
day and it worked what is them some 200
gonna happen we're at 160 for 36
February cool yeah ooh we could time it
right around the book March 8th
they're really really nice to charge
like come in like and I want the tickets
to be actually we may have to reverse
engineer this what we can do is look
like getting in the door you have to
come with 6 bucks like that's your entry
point I'm a hustler right hook anything
else one more on this Friday and then my
official prediction nope but I'm more
prepared than I have was for the Buffalo
game
weirdly from Craig Craig Craig Mack no
just Cragen Reese job
preg ask how do I stop my competition
from telling blatant lies about my
business without stooping to their level
Craig by recognizing those blatant lies
have no impact on your future now stick
with me here it's hard because you'll
say no way Gary it's already had an
impact this person stopped working with
me because of that lie
net net with me my friend net net with
me if they're lies and they may not be
let's first make sure they're lies my
man but if they're lies you will win
lies have been people tried that tactic
on me you will never ever win that game
if you're on the lying end look the
truth is undefeated you just have to be
patient so the the fact of the matter is
it's too much on your mind by you even
asking me this question
it's bubbled up and it's really no
different I'm starting to use this
because it's an extreme version of an
atomically top of everybody's mind it's
really in some weird way no different
than terrorism like terrorism works
because people get scared and that's
what the prop it's propaganda right and
of course things happen but what they're
trying to do is get people not to fly
not to go to Europe like you all these
things a security they make these videos
and say we're gonna go after all these
places to scare people in those places
that's how it works well that's what
that is as well which is like they're
trying to propaganda your clients into
believing that but when there's a net
result a year later two years later when
people like ah Gary is just good at
Twitter vaynermedia is not mean you mean
people said vaynermedia was gonna fail
because I'm just a social media pundit
I'm just [ __ ] and pizzazz I'm all
this well they lost because now here we
are and so as long as you're confident
in your execution please do not spend
time going on the defense against your
competitors who are lying about you just
go do your thing and let the results
show for themselves this is a very
important thing people get way too hung
up on their negative comments on YouTube
they're the competition making lies
about them the results always speak for
themselves Marky Mark was not going to
transition into a real celebrity until
Mark Wahlberg did it Justin Bieber was
always just gonna be a teenybopper until
he put out fire right like like the
truth always wins
period
cool question today what is your truth
who are you at the truest level let's
see how many of you and by the way I
only expect three of you one on YouTube
two on Facebook to actually answer this
truth because the rest of you are gonna
PR it and put up some [ __ ] but for
the three of you and I'm gonna try to
read them all to see which three say it
who are you what's the real truth about
yourself and the reason I'm doing it is
for the three of you that actually write
it and expose it to the world
your Saturday or Sunday depending on
when you watch us will be different for
the rest of your life and with some big
stuff there
jet 16 Texans 13 just are gonna go in
there win TJ Yeats backup quarterback
I'm worried about the defense I know the
Texans have not given up a touchdown in
10 quarters but I think the Jets go in
their season on the line the Jets know
if they lose this game they will not
make the playoffs 1613 New York Jets I
look for Eric Decker to have a huge day
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]